One of the things I try to avoid on this show is
to be hyperbolic, and when people are going crazy
about something and it's really no big deal, I
try to just say this is really not that big of a
deal. Let's talk about it, but let's talk about
it in sort of sober and reasonable terms. But
that is very much not the case when it comes to
the peril that is on the horizon. If Republicans
were to win the 2022 midterm elections in what are
just a few months now, quite frankly. And when I
say democracy is in jeopardy if Republicans take
the House in 2022, I say it with the caveat that
this is not a hyperbolic claim. And increasingly,
I mean, the bad thing is that democracy is in
peril if Republicans win. The good thing is
increasingly people are understanding this
peril and this risk Republicans and Democrats who
are so similar on so many issues. We've talked
about it before. Here's a whole bunch of issues
on which there's really no significant difference
between Republicans and Democrats. How could it be
that if Republicans take one chamber of Congress,
it would have such a major impact, and the answer
is that it is because of the destructive potential
that the series of events that could be unleashed
by Republicans taking control of the House
is so significant that it could be the
catalyst for a disaster for democracy,
and let's just think it through. First, we
know that Republicans see their 2020 failure
as a failure to steal the election. What I mean by
that is when you hear Republicans talk about 2020,
most of them, I mean, OK, Mitt Romney's the
exception. Liz Cheney is the exception. But for
the most part, when you hear Trump people
associated with the Trump White House, the more
weaponized Republicans in the House and Senate,
when they talk about what happened in 2020,
their view is we. We just didn't do enough
to take the election from the guy who won
it. They don't think, you know, next time
we should really win by appealing to more
voters and getting more people to vote for
us. That would be the normal reaction. That
would be the pro-democracy reaction. Not
enough. We didn't convince enough people,
let's be better at convincing people to vote for
us. No. They think we can win next time by better
working to take the election, even when we don't
win it using different techniques or being better
with the techniques that we used in 2022. But we
just didn't do enough of so. With a midterm 2020
to win, they would be far better to carry out that
upending of democracy in 2024. That's a very
dangerous thing. Secondly, Marjorie Taylor Greene,
Matt Gates and others in that cohort have said,
If we win in 2022, we are going to investigate Joe
Biden. We're going to investigate Hunter Biden,
who has nothing to do with the administration.
We will end the January 6th committee. If it's
still going on, we will impeach Joe Biden and
on and on and on. They've said that that's what
they're going to do disaster. And thirdly, they've
said if they win, they will quickly work to
help the Trump rioters avoid consequences to any
extent that they can, effectively rewarding the
rioters for what they did on January 6th of 2021.
Now, in response to this, Nancy Pelosi, who I am
not a fan of Nancy Pelosi, recently said quote, It
is absolutely essential for our democracy that we
win. I fear for our democracy. If the Republicans
were ever to get the gavel, we can't let that
happen. And some people think she's being
hyperbolic. But remember that Canadian political
scientist Thomas Homer Dixon, who we interviewed
recently, he also wrote and explained to us during
the interview that the United States could be
under a right wing dictatorship by 2030. And when
I asked him what talk to us about the sequence?
What are the initial steps and the precursor steps
to a right wing dictatorship in 2030 include Trump
waiting in 2024, and a precursor to that would,
of course, be Republicans taking the House
in 2022. So the stakes are absolutely huge.
And if we just say what's most likely,
I'm not saying throw in the towel. I'm not
saying don't try. If anything, what I'm saying
is we've got to try. The more likely outcome,
even though Nancy Pelosi won't admit it, is that
Republicans take the House in 2022 if nothing
significant changes. Republicans only have to
flip five seats. Remember to take control of the
House in November. That's the most likely outcome
that they are able to flip at least five seats.
It is a very small margin of error for Democrats.
Now the other aspect to all of this is, of course.
Is the Department of Justice going to act at all
to show that what took place in 2020 simply cannot
happen again and truly hold people accountable? I,
you know, I have no emotional investment in
Merrick Garland one way or the other. But
it's increasingly looking like Merrick Garland is
sort of spineless, and we're going to talk later